i was just saying congratulations to you
too but here's where i'm gonna get on
you
because why did i go all the way to
berlin for this movie
never see you never know never nothing
i'm like
lauren is in this movie oh
may we miss each other yeah yeah we went
all the way
and i'm like how did we not how did i
not get to see lauren
oh wow i was in and out i was in and out
it was um
it was a very uh uh it was a crazy time
in my life
and so um i was in and out of hurricane
get back home to the kids
so but tell me how this was for you i
can
i can only imagine it was a release to
be back in a creative space to really be
you know doing what you love and back in
this fold what was that time like
for you we shot it in 2019
i believe and forgive me my memory
doesn't serve me so well
after grief and everything um and
michael uh reached out to me as a friend
and he was so unsure if i was
even going to ever work again he was
like look i
am unsure if this is what you want to do
but i have to follow my intuition i have
to ask you can you just read the script
and i was like no no i'm kind of like
it's a lot going on in my world and
there were other priorities
and so i read it and she passes away
and then i also saw throughout the film
that she
comes to him and her energy and her
essence and that
her love for him is still guiding him
and i felt so connected to that just in
my own personal experience
yeah that i felt like i could contribute
here
and moving forward in my life i kind of
don't want to do anything that i can't
really truthfully
contribute and i felt like i could
truthfully
contribute to this project well first of
all that gives me goosebumps
just hearing you say that and um i'm not
a
i don't believe in coincidences i
believe everything is in its divine
order and it's always written so this
was meant for you to do
in a lot of ways probably to help heal
you in so many ways
and you know what it's not a bad day at
the office to get to play house with the
man that people say are the sexiest
um more importantly i felt um
comfortable
and protected around him and that's what
is is really
um important in this situation i love
that he brought you back in the fold
lovingly and like a brother
and really you know um seeing you work
like i just said when i popped on here
was just really really good to see your
face
um how much because you guys were
friends you probably had an automatic
chemistry but was there a bit of a
process kind of getting into that dance
of
uh you know a married couple and kind of
how they move how you move in that space
um because you are the emotional heart
and soul of
this yeah but you know i think just you
know my experience of just
my own loving relationship with my
beloved
um me being a mother um
it's not hard for me to tap into my
tenderness at 36 i'm 36 so when i was
younger i didn't have too much
experience and
love and care and vulnerability
and i think now just at my age and just
my experience in love
um no it wasn't hard
i think also just being um so vulnerable
in life and open
you just go with it
do you think lauren that it was
important too for your for your babies
to see you taking steps back to getting
into the work yeah mm-hmm and yeah
getting that example
110 um
because we can't live in our caves we
can't stop
you know we do have a purpose all of us
and um it's important for my sons to see
me moving forward with grief
not just um curling up in the ball cause
i crawled up in a ball for a long time
but
especially for my eldest son because
he's just a little bit more aware
that you know we will be sad and we will
grieve for a long time
forever but that we will continue moving
on
as we have to as nip would want us to
i love that um too on the two-year
anniversary of his passing you had such
a beautiful tribute
that that you wrote and and
you know the talks that you have with
your youngest son do you just pour into
him who his daddy
you know is and and was and and kind of
his walk through the world because we
all you know you talk about the the
grind and the hustle
and and the you know all of those things
and that's who we know
nipsey to have been yeah
you know it's one of the reasons why i
have nips uh
notes on my arm and his portrait on my
um
arm it's not always for me it's for my
son to
always see his father i love him you
know
my son's every time he sees his mom he
sees his dad and um
you know our nip is very alive in our
household
oh yeah he's a woman he acts very much
like his father
well you know what that's actually i
think probably soul soothing for you in
some ways
to know that um so you know this film
like so many others have has been pushed
and pulled in here and there and this
date and that date are you really
are you happy that finally we're gonna
get to see
you know what you guys uh have been
working yeah and
i think you know i believe in divine
order yeah so i believe that everything
happens for a reason and that april 30th
is exactly
the time and the date it was supposed to
happen
you know i'm more into the flow of life
you got to be you got you have to be you
know what i'm saying that's all that
fuels us
right now and especially you like you've
got to be and
and i just want you to know before we
leave like and i know you know this but
i want you to hear it
we all pull for you pray for you love
you
like want to fuel you um just are proud
of you
like so yeah i just want you
the collective is extremely important
and we are all connected
and um man i think prayers outside of my
personal family have kept me influenced